we got Kevon and then later Tommy Lee
Jones came on board and that's the cast
of JFK 25 years later the cast of JFK
reunites for the thriller criminal out
Friday ET sat down with the film stars
Gary Oldman and a Kevin Costner it was
really amazing to see the two of them
and be with them and just watch the
three of us we're all gray I said the
one thing I notice is that that we moved
we moves more slowly than we did and we
make noises and when we get out of
chairs we go back to the set yeah we
were young thing also starring in
criminal our new Wonder Woman gal gadot
she's a wonderful woman and and she was
really good in our movie but she was a
good partner like I said I'd never met
her I come out of the trailer looking
pretty much like I just Frankenstein
almost and and I have to say to her hi
I'm Kevin Kloster she tells me her name
I said we're gonna do a rape scene right
now yeah and she just takes anybody goes
and but she was a good sport
you know and we were respectful of each
other
Kevin and Gary our previous members of
the DC Universe JK Simmons will take
over Gary's role as Commissioner Gordon
in Justice League absolutely happy to be
pleased he can have Jim Gordon with my
blessing
I hope he's fantastic in it
you